(Transcribed by TurboScribe.ai. Go Unlimited to remove this message.) Okay, Namdi, this video is on PLP, Ontological Bayesian Intelligence
System.
So, I've got this video ready, but I think I
lost it.
So, what is PLP?
PSP stands for Phenomenological Lensing Principle or Phenomenological Lensing
Protocol.
It really means Ontological Bayesian Intelligence Infrastructure.
Like, you know, my PhD is on Ontological Bayesian Infra
-intelligence, but, you know, that means small stuff.
So, the term Ontological, the nature of knowing yourself, you
know, know yourself, to know who you are, you know,
your BFN history.
Ontological, who, what, why, when, why, you know, how to
build your stuff.
So, Ontological means, like, role, like, you know, I know
my goal, I know my purpose, I know what to
do next.
Now, the Bayesian means, like, probability of it, Bayesian inference,
like, you know, half and half on the Bayesian graph.
The thing about Bayesian is, you know, you have to
get the probability of range, you know, like, you know,
something can be 0.5 to 0.9, but that's
when the function is coherent and the function works and
the thing works.
That's Bayesian inference.
Intelligence, AI intelligence, smart devices, things that don't need
consciousness, model, you know, my lead architect and system architect.
Ontological or Bayesian reasoning, probability.
Rhetorical or reasoning, like, you know, for AI systems, you
know, you can use that to ensure an AI makes
the right decision based in real time, you know, when
something is an edge case.
The rhetoric means, like, you know, my rhetorical reasoning, like,
you know, it's just talk, but it means something, it
has some grounding, but, you know, it's not practical.
Maybe practical, yes, it can be practical, definitely, but, you
know, it's something like an edge case we haven't really
encountered, you know, it has to absorb that, you know,
by itself.
That's what the rhetoric reasoning, rationale, like, you know, the
rationale behind doing that.
So I changed the rationale, you know.
The goal is to define a suppose of this ABC.
Okay, now, the goal of this is to have a
dual model, observer to consumer.
Now, remember, guys, the observer model is just what, you
know, it bubbles up errors.
It doesn't propagate any errors downstream.
It bubbles up the source code error.
And the event loop is witnessing all the time for
the state change, based on local maximum and local minima.
So when a programme observes its state, it's really observing
the local minima, the changes it does, and what it
does, what's going to change, what's not going to change,
you know, and then it changes what's going to change.
It's like a, it's just witnesses, and that's called witnessing.
So when it witnesses, the time-preserved portfolio time, that
acts as a factor of four of the time.
Because the other thing, you know, the factor of four
is just a standard testing, but the 4.5 is
just the other one.
So, this is like, this is what we interpret.
The PhD on direct instruction, direct simulation systems, which are
treated in the same thing, observer to consumer.
Observer to consumer in quantum systems, you know, you can't
really observe, when you want to change in a quantum
state, oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no.
So basically there's an ad there, let me just pause
it.
So you don't want to have an interpreter state, you
know, mangled or wrangled or all that stuff.
So basically, OBS interpreter, any Python or Python, any polyglot
interpreter must cohere, like you know, it must be working
with the Gussie manuscript, the Gussie language polyglot manuscript.
Now, the manuscripts aren't really defined properly, but you know,
we need an explanation for interpreter, because interpreter for Python,
doesn't really differ from interpreter for Lua, etc.
So the goal of this is to observe that the
interpreter, a photocard system, is a song for the interpreter
to Lua system, via a Gussie lang polyglot manuscript, .gsm
files, .gs files for Gussie lang.
Now, the Gussie lang files are just polyglot files, it's
just like a polyglot.
So the goal of this is to have the .gs
files, .gsm files, which is the interpreter layer.
So let me give you an example, so Python can
define something called bi-weekly, once in every two weeks,
you know, once every two weeks, or once, you know,
is it once of every two weeks, or once bi
-weekly, so ambiguity in the term bi-weekly, or bi
-daily, let's say it's bi-weekly, once in two weeks,
you know, something happens in one week, every two weeks,
one in, in, but then it's off, one off, one,
every time, once off two weeks, you know, that's the
thing.
So every once a week, you skip two weeks, you
don't do it for two weeks.
Every one in the two weeks, you know, the interpretation
is on or off, you know, it's like an in
or off loop, you know, that's the bi-weekly or
bi-daily interpretation.
So Python might interpret this one way, and then Luam
has to go the other way, you know, based on
whatever the standard specification is, because these are interpreted
languages, not compiled, that execute as you run it, they're
not compiled, they have a runtime to add byte-byte
in the real world, and as I'm saying, the goal
of this is just to have a system that understands
this concept, and can infer from the new and better
three AVL nodes, three AVL red-black animation, which red
-black animation is just a standard algorithm I'm using to
animate all the red redundant nodes from a system that
needs black batteries, you know, and as I say, no,
the red-black animation is just a standard for it.
Now, for the quantum computers, you're going to understand that
the observer-consumer model had another hook attached.
So for example, if you observe, you know, the observer,
you can't observe a state and change something in quantum
computing, you only observe something in concepts in a quantum
system, so you have to ensure that you can act
before you can, you know, consume.
So for example, if I'm observing, I can have a
pre-observed model, pre-observed, you know, something like a
pre-event, a bubble, an event loop, that witnesses.
So when an event pre-happens before another event, that's
the duality that acts on that event, because the system
needs the next state of that information.
So you can create the information, you can get the
information you need before you ever observe, or you can
get the observation, you run the code, act, consume, before
the function caller, callee, uses it.
Now we've got, so we've got a matrix, 0, 0,
1, 2, 3, in, off, so you've got like an
in, off, if you just remember, for in loop, for
off loop, you know, these are just standard loops for
the interpretation layer.
You can try to understand this more formally, you know,
to ensure that the system understands the concept and can
resolve itself based on the aviary rotation for that set
structure, the bi-query key.
We are a bi-DAG.
Okay, now, very important, the bi-DAG stands for bi
-directional DAG, it's like, it's a bit of the things
that are interpreted by most of the context.
So everything that's interpreted has two states, you know, it
can be either one state or the other state, so
it's kind of weird to, you have to rotate to
ensure that the system is flexible.
So the thing about the bi-interpreter, or the bi
-interpreter, is that they have a bi-directional, bi-directional
interpretation, it can mean one thing to one system, and
another thing to another system, but you know, that's what's
quite humorous about it.
It reminds me of AI host solutioning system.
You can stop an AI host system with this framework
too.
This one's important.
So if you go to github.com slash o-g
-h-e, drive, or like a drive, you know, I
think that means like a web drive, yeah, so it's
an Apple web drive, but you know, that web drive
is for the AI system.
So you get like a very important item.
So basically, how this interpretation stops the AI from working
incoherently is this.
So remember those things you did at school?
20 equals 8, 25 equals
10, and 6 equals 3.
What is 5 equals 1?
So this is just another implementation.
This is called my anti-AI hallucination system.
So basically, this 10, this is a system of linear
equations, but you know, the goal is for you to
understand what's happening here.
So you see 8 equals, 20 equals 8.
This is 25.
This is just one system of linear equations, but you
know, it's like a puzzle really.
It's a puzzle.
It's like one of those puzzles that gives you, so
20 equals 8 means one system's 20 is one system's
8, you know, another one's 8.
So there's a layer between, when you have an 8
in a Python file, you know, or number 8, you
know, what is 8 made of?
That's 20 in like a Lua, or C.
20 in Lua, because Lua is an interpretive language.
So when you have 25 in Lua, you have 10
in Python.
When you have 6 in Lua, you have 3.
And then when you have 5 in Python, Lua, you
have X.
But what is X?
We don't know X.
The goal of this thing is to ensure that the
AI or systems that are active never hallucinate or make
up their own interpretation of that assisted.
It must resolve the bi-directional, bi-directional directed side
-click graph with open access derivational tracing system to trace
all the sequences and the series of function calls.
Recursively, not imprecursively, but you know, it's resolving a circular
dependency to ensure that every dependency has a telemetry ID,
which is called a unique user ID, for that local
scope, local maximum scope, local minimum scope, based on what
is allowed to execute.
Now, this puzzle can be geometric as well.
It can be like a square.
This is like a cube, or it can be a
mathematical geometry.
This represents two acres, you know, two land, you know,
two land.
You know, this is like an example.
These are auxiliary constructions, you know.
They geometrically are things you make to solve the problem,
you know.
And this puzzle is just either geometric or algebraic puzzles,
which I call them.
They are geometric or algebraic.
Because, you know, they can be in the form of
a graph, a diagram like this, or it can be
a form of anything else.
Okay, Namdi, 3, 2, 1, pause.
Namdi, 3, 2, 1, take a picture.
Okay, so this is a puzzle here.
It can be a puzzle here.
But the thing about this number system is, you know,
this number system is non-universal.
We've never seen the number...
What is universal concepts?
You know, it's a concept we use.
We've never seen an actual number 9, because the number
9 in French, we've never seen the number 9 in
French.
A, B, C, D, F, G, that's it.
But, you know, we've only seen the number 3 in
real life, walking about, you know, Hi, I'm number 3.
But, you know, I'm the only number 3.
You haven't seen the number 1, 2, 3.
You haven't seen 3.
The number 3, you know, 3 in French, you know,
the spelt in French way, you know, walking about, it's
not an actual concept.
That's what I'm saying.
This system must remain coherent by the way they're modelled.
And this is why the PLP is the mother of
the pathological Bayesian infrastructure.
So, my goal is to ensure this works coherently.
I can try to say that, you know, this is
just a puzzle, yes, but you know, this can mean
a geometric alignment or a system, it's for anti-AI
isolation.
So I'm going to try to anti-AI, how do
you say, so the AI cannot isolate and interpret via
interpretation.
Too much interpretation.
So, basically, the ten of others is to remove a
vector bi-weekly, bi-daily, ensure it's a bi-DAG,
bi-organised digital trading system bag.
The sequence of instructions or sequence of series of steps,
a sequence is just a non-alternate series, but you
know, a series is what can alternate, can split between
interpretation based on context.
Which is context switching?
But you know, context switching, not code switching.
Because, you know, switching context is based on the user's
needs, you know, inputs.
Now, this is part of the Functor Frameworks.
Now, Functor Frameworks is very important for this, because those
are the mappings for the system.
If everything is a functor in an infrastructure, then you
can evolve it easier and seamlessly.
There's no need to slap a new component in it,
a new component.
Phenomenology-Phenomenal Protocol, consumer to observer, you know, it can
be resolved like that, it can go from observer to
consumer, consumer to observer, observer to consumer, in any way,
shape you want, but the goal is to resolve the
state of mind.
Functor...
So, PLP, Objective of PLP Framework.
Now, PLP stands for, just like example here, you can
see this, PLP.
So basically, the PLP stands for Phenomenology Learning Principle.
HOLE, now, HOLE stands for Homogeneous, or HOME.
I call it HOM, Homogeneous.
Now, you see this data 0, 0 here, this one
is uniform.
It goes like, 0, 0, so this is an input
to the matrix, 0, 0.
Now if you get another matrix, you get 0, 0,
you get the same matrix, 0, 0, you get 1,
1, you get 1, 1, same, you know, same.
And this is a PLP, here, here's just data, but
you know, it can be, it can be anything, but
it's just a standard form of it.
Now, anything that's input to this matrix is the input.
It can be in a vector form, sparse, it can
be in the same form, but you know, depending on
how you want to use it, you know, how the
data is structured, how you want to best transverse the
graph of the data, based on the open access deregistration
code, but you know, the goal of this vector is
to align with a uniform structure.
If it's heterogeneous data inputs, you know, that is a
uniform and can be modelled quickly.
This can be defined as sparse.
So the sparse concept is like, you know, if I
want to model some information in a uniform manner, you
know, I'll define that uniform thing, input, as the model,
in the model, because you know, if I have like
a data structure for a person's student ID, I don't
mix it with student credit card or bank card ID,
because you know, that's not identified by all the students,
but if I have a student number, student name, student
name is me, first name is Namdi, Namdi, second name
is Appala, and then DOB is my domain.
This is not a uniform data, because you know, this
is a uniform stream of information, just the first name
is what, a string, and then the second name is
a string, and the DOB is my domain.
Now, this applies to all homogenous data, but you know,
if I then have a, if I want to store
a unique key, which is called a key, a foreign
key, the foreign key, a recent ID, a foreign key,
and I put that there, and that foreign key, you
can use to go on the next student ID, but
you know, if it's not coherent, if it's not, if
it's like, if the information is not coherent, I can
get like a non-uniform model.
Oh, sorry, sorry, this is a non-uniform model, sorry.
So this one is non-uniform, because you know, it
has a, it represents a student, enough about a student,
a student name and number, kind of a boring, a
student name is like Namdi, and the other name is
string, but you know, so that's just one side of
it that's uniform, there's two strings there, now, the, what
is it called, it's uniform, because it has two strings
there, that's the first and last, but it makes it
non-uniform, because the date of birth is a, oh,
sorry, it's a string, so it's uniform, so it's, you
know, you put in the 19th of November, if I
put it in 2001, sorry, 19th of May 2001, that's
uniform, because they're all strings.
Now, if I ever put my age there, my age
string, four years old, and then age is 24 years
old, that becomes a non-uniform data, because you know,
there's something there, the data is non-uniform, you know,
you can put in another data structure, or we can
handle it another way, but you know, that data can
be something else, it can, it's structured, the model is
still structured, but the sparse locality construct, because you know,
I don't need it, if I want to define a
function now, I have to either, and this model doesn't
need the age, it doesn't have to need add the
age, you know, you don't need the age at all,
so you just need to discard the age, you know,
it doesn't need it, you can just make it private,
you can define it between a functor, you can define
a structure that handles the names, the string datatype, and
the names and the numbers, you know, this is called
a schema, this is what the OpenAccess schema is about.
Now, the schema for OpenAccess is services dot operation dot
openaccess dot division dot department dot county dot org, so
basically, that schema is a by DAG resolution case for
the KNN cluster of the search engine, so basically, if
you search for plasma services plasma systems dot operation services
brain computing interfaces dot operation plasmoid systems plasmoid systems
like, you know, plasma technology I'm making, dot openaccess dot
department, department is sales department and dot division computing dot
county county or ha county, the public housing dot o
-h-a and each i-j-a means like order
count dot org, and that's what I'm saying.
So, this function would ensure that the isomorphic layer between
the data is met with the interpretation of the OpenAccess
to resolve a system using the the puzzle framework, you
know, the kind of puzzle you're going to do as
a child, like one number is another number, two sticks
equals one big stick, you know, and ensure it works,
you know.
Now, that's what PSP's sparse data is, this is sparse
enough, because, you know, the sparse data is uniform, and
uniform data is the same type and everything, you know,
everything is consistent in the, you know, going from input,
you know, there's no different type.
Now, you get a PLP on non-uniform, which is
you know, non-uniformity in the data, but the same,
basically, the sparse they do the same thing, but the
they have the same model of that data structure, but
they're different, because you know, they are Hamiltonian resolved and
you know, basically, the Hamiltonian, basically, the one or zero,
one to zero, one, you know, is different, because, you
know, it means the same thing, but it's just a
different way of doing it, representing that same information or
problem, you know, it's like, you know, it's a bad
direction.
So, basically, I'm trying to explore you guys to explore,
I want you guys to explore this one, try to
implement a student ID system with a telemetry tracker that
ensures the schema of the system is null, nil, and
nil to null to data, but you know, if the
data is nil, there's no memory, no type, no value,
and then that's nothing to be used, and then that
will be reset to nil if there's nothing to be
collected, because the goal of this is to have the
bits fields aligned.
For example, if you have a RIFT system, RIFT ecosystem,
I'll just write it down here.
So, basically, I'm saying that the system for RIFT is,
like, RIFT stands for RIFT is a flexible translator, and
RIFT must ensure that the system is nil when you
have, like, a schema, a schema with, like, a nil
template, you know, nothing is being stored in the system,
and how RIFT handles schema is null, nil, nil will
be the default placeholder for no value, no memory, no
type, but, you know, the goal is for every data
structure to have something I call a bits field, like,
you know, the bits field is a memory allocator, you
know, say the string a string, it's 8 bytes, no,
a character is 8 bytes, how much is a string?
I don't know, but, you know, the size of the
string is, like, you know, a void pointer is a
nil, a void pointer is nil, a pointer to nothing,
nothing, before the memory is allocated, you know, you point
to nothing, that's a void pointer, but the size of
a data structure, size of a void pointer, a void
type, so, the null type is nothing, the null type
is the size of the void pointer, and that's what
the null type is, and the null type is nothing
being allocated and point to user and the data itself,
so I'm saying to you, you can define a programme
and a student ID that has a schema to resolve
students in a boarding school, so you've got the children,
I was in Queen of England boarding school, you've got
the children, and then you've got the young people, and
you've got the adults, the young people, and then you've
got the 18 years old, 20 years old, 22, it
doesn't matter, so the struggle would be to have the
data set again, and then the young people have different
kind of data, you know, there are still students yet,
but they have different requirements, so basically, the age of
the child is 1 to 12, 13 to 18, and
18 to 25, that's when you leave the boarding school,
that's when you're done with education anyway, so that's what
I'm saying to you, so the thing about this, you're
going to have a system that expresses null as null,
so basically, if I want a child, there has to
be some kind of coherence between the service offering and
the null template for the schema, based on spots, so
I can say children, uniform children, children type, age, date
of birth, but you know, everything about child type in
a computer, so I can say the child is male,
boy or girl, that's a Boolean, now this Boolean is
a Boolean data, a structured data, now, I get the
structure, the end is a bool, bool, neurodivergent, neurodivergent, that's
a bool, and then you have something else, that's just
one output, and then look here, I can put the
date of birth, the DLB, and the year, DLB is
name, name, name, first name, last name, and that would
be strings, strings, strings, and that would be it, and
then you can put this as a date time, but
the string is possible, so date time, so you can
think about things like that, if the system can represent
the data, because you know, basically, you can put a
calendar system here, but you know, in the database, it's
not a calendar system anymore, it's just a string, so
I can just put the calendar format here, and ISO
format, and then we'll have no, no, no, and then
that would be it, things like that, you know, to
ensure the system can maintain coherence over the life cycle
of that system, you know, using the derivation system to
create derivatives of the change, you know, if a system
needs something in a bidirectional way, handling interpretations for people,
especially as a first principle of that system, you know,
what could a first principle be, the first thing you
think of when you use a system, you know, it
just works the way it is, and to mitigate fear,
uncertainty, and doubt, that's the framework I've developed, so I
hope you guys take this video with the utmost dignity,
because this is what I'm saying, the PRP framework is
really about ensuring that the consumer can act and they
have coherence, it can work, it knows what it does,
why it does it, and why it's acting the way
it is, it doesn't hallucinate, because, you know, you can't
hallucinate, because, you know, the system resolves it kind of
a polygon manner, because, you know, if you have a
system that represents one thing one way, and the system
has an interpretation of that which represents it, it has
to be coherent between the two systems, and that's where
the puzzle, so remember, the puzzle for the thing is
like 20 equals 25 or something like that, no, 1
equals 6 when you get one unit or something you
get 6 of it on the other side, you know
that's what I'm saying, because, you know, these are definitions
of like a Python tuple, and a C struct, and,
you know, a Python dictionary, a Python dictionary, different between
a Python dictionary and a C structure, you know, they
represent objects, but they're different models of objects, you know,
the Python dictionary has different operations it can perform, and
that's what the same thing, they're not as much in
a standardised relation for the lilies of C, C structure
is not equivalent to a Python dictionary, and that's what
I'm basically talking about, the data models, how you model
that.
One more thing, the verb-noun counter-relation, you know,
as a standard specification, you guys should remember this, you
must remember this, it's a policy, it's a policy map,
no one should mess it up, you know, enforces as
a specification, you know, I want you guys to think
about this properly.
So if I have an error, something called a verb
-noun error, 1 to 5 is my error threshold, now,
that 1 to 5 is a low to high warning,
1, low, 2, low, medium, 3, medium, 4, medium, high,
and 5, high.
That warning system, so after the short coherence, so basically,
if I have a class, class low, low, low what?
Low warning.
Low warning error.
But this low warning, class low warning, this is like
a low warning, so the verb is what?
Low.
Low warning.
Medium warning.
Low-medium warning.
Medium-high warning.
Medium-high warning and high warning.
So this is 1 to 5, just like a system.
So basically, this is like a verb-noun pair, so
the low is the verb, it's low, it's low, low,
verb, noun, and the noun is a warning, you know,
it's warning you to, that you know, and that's like
a Python class, you can call it a class called
low warning.
It's a policy now, guys, enforce it everywhere you write
a code.
So if you write a code in OBS, you've got
to ensure that it's not something you bubble to, and
you bubble to a low warning, a low warning.
This is now represented in enum, you know, the enum
transition between the low warning states, and then you go
to the 6 to 11, which is part 5, and
you get the exceptions model.
Now, the exceptions is dual, so basically, as you can
go up, you can probably get to, can be interpreted
in two ways, you know, because you know, I want
to show you guys the standard, so the interpretation of
the exception is bidirectional, you know, so I can have
a warning in one system and not have a warning
in the other.
So again, what's my warning?
You know, what's my information?
It's not coming through.
And then you go, oh, there's an exception.
So the exception could be a low, low warning, a
low warning exception, low exception warning, low exception warning, but
you know, low warning exception, low warning error, low error
warning, low error warning, low warning, basically, this ensures that
the schema is flexible for you to remember what it
is.
Low exception warning to a high exception warning.
The goal of this is to ensure that everything you
write is, you know, can be tested, can be audited.
Just by looking at it, you know, auditing just means
you can fix it, you can try to fix the
little things, the nuances.
Auditing is just like inspecting, it's really introspection, inspecting that
this code is what it is you're trying to model.
You know, auditing is like, am I getting this code
right?
Can I see this function when I need to see
it?
Can I access it when I need to access it?
Can I, you know, that's what I'm saying, the audit
is very important for the tracing of the function calls
via the functions, which is markers of the functions in
that state's mind.
So what I'm saying to you, the goal of this
is to ensure that everything is standardised and conventional, this
is a verb noun model, which is like a verb
noun DAG, like a fast car, a speeding train, no,
no, wrong again, okay, a shaking dog, a shivering dog,
a shivering dog, that's a model, this is a shivering
dog, it can be a story or something, but a
shivering dog is a shivering cat, something that shivers, something
that's quiver, a fiat, a large mouse, the large mouse
is just a verb noun, so you've got to ensure
that the system is coherent for your own concept, this
is a concept for the model, so it's like the
verb is what?
The action to do, to act, to do, to use,
to walk, to talk, to fart, to laugh, that's the
verb, the verb is a doing word, and you can
add a verb if you want, an adverb to do,
like doing now, the adverb is just doing now, just
make sure it's the verb, because the adverb is just
doing something in the past, present or future, there's constraints
on it, you can use it to log errors,